[Musica]
nella vita ragazzi tutto occorre cioè
voi in questo momento state vivendo un
momento della vostra vita al 99 per
cento di voi che un giorno invidie rete
di reti ma da quanto ritornare a quel
tempo anche se questo punto hai dei
problemi di sci madonna sono così perché
ciò la scuola e veri get palle un giorno
invidie rai pensando a quello che sta
vivendo adesso quindi goditi ogni
momento ho fatto un travestito
filosofica in realtà perché se avesse
scriverla alza al limite beh questo è
uno dei momenti ei questioni date non
sono passati così tanti anni avevo già
fatto un altro episodio di iscriverla un
sempre per ricordare i vecchi tempi no e
mi andava di ricordarli oggi sono un po
qua nostalgico e gioca scrive la voglia
fare un episodio su script se non è la
meta foresta non mi ricordo neanche più
oddio perché volo a volo perché
veramente me lo ski mi ero iscritto con
volo tra le features va bene ragazzi per
chi non lo sapesse scrive l'ansa litico
è a limitate quel gioco è uno dei
primissimi giochi comprato sul canale
appunto ti permetterà di fare un sacco
di roba
in questo gioco tu puoi scrivere e
quelle cose che tu scrivi succedono
succedono veramente quindi adesso vado
nelle rovine di ellissi che non lo
cagate di striscio e propria visto
scappare qualcosa salve tu puoi scrivere
qualsiasi cosa anche fa vj e lui ti ti
ti fa uscire le robe capito quindi
questo gioco veramente magico bellissimo
perché che è successo qua ci sta un
salve asp è che c'è una sfida scrivo è
questo un leggendario viaggio va bene
che bello tutte cosine che la logora
fatto solo un cavaliere prepara gli
avventurieri per una ricerca etica dai
al guerriero un'arma va bene sonaglio
combatti ai guerrieri tutti i guerrieri
o che a tutti non aprendo la bravissimo
e all'altro di do un retino bene
la donna come li sto armando che il
signore degli anelli proprio ok
e poi una canna da pesca ok questo tipo
un death note quello che ho che mi
permette di scrivere oggetto qualsiasi
cosa vi viene in mente io la posso
creare dare alla gente c'è questo è un
concept di gioco pazzesco se ci pensate
però
non penso che io debba dati veramente
delle vere armi da eppure andava bene
anche col sonaglio ma porca vacca al
brigante piace stare fuori ha da mischia
dagli un'arma che possono usare dalla
distanza
va bene a giocava bene aspetta la
pentola posta posto la pentola andava
bene go stregoni ho messo di oggi ad
allenare ma che gli permette di sorrisi
poteri magici il retino a posto bene la
guaritrice ha un ruolo di supporto dalle
qualcosa preferire gli altri membri del
gruppo che siringa che gliele in fila
del ciappetta la gente vai
eccolo ragazzi ditemi se scrive la
fecola pentola vai affrontare il drago
ditemi se non era il gioco migliore
della storia proprio generale dai
madonna che gioca incredibile combatti
corre tino bravo poco kura kura kura
kura la gente quasi linga cura o mio dio
è la siringa di quelle che ti rieti può
nascere di e la madonna con
lanciarazzi
va bene era la mia seconda scelta dal
lione al cerasi effettivamente a tutti
ma c'è una spanna gigante la voglio io
fatemelo a prendere che mi sa di spada
fortissima tanto persona st wright
lestamente sono delle cose che puoi
prendere quando finisce le emissioni in
scrive non era così facile prendere
silenzio non ospe non ho perso la mia è
la mia il mio tatto ecco vanta continua
messo anche la supervelocità che non
sono uscite semplicemente iscrivi blocco
appunti aggiunge aggettivo volante e
veloce infatti puzzolente averi che sarà
lascio gli aloni verdi va bene salve
aiutami a trovare le ossa di cristallo
del re e liszt ellissi va bene io no ho
sbagliato vabbé fa niente va bene eccola
l'ho trovata cerchiara aiuto non riesco
a schivare questi dati impazziti aspetta
muro ecco qua
hai visto tu protetto io devo prendere
un attimo questo perché deve votarlo
allo zio di la riva pieni a lei consegna
a posto e sono usciti altri due va bene
nasce ancora qualcosa di qua
freddie mercury ecco appunto
allora cascate di anafora l'avevo fatte
prove cioè freddi non sento i raggi del
sole vicino al fiume si crei qualcosa
per farmi abbronzare crema solare ma che
ne so io avevo già fatta avevo già fatta
che sette anni fa quando ho fatto il
primo video di scrivere non aveva
funzionato che ne so per farti abbronza
allo specchio
così ti riflettono i raggi andò fco
eccolo i sette anni sono diventati voi
non l'avete visto perché la sotto la mia
webcam è letteralmente esploso freddie
mercury e adesso io sto beatamente
prendendo il sole come se niente fosse
ma esploso freddie mercury
ok damigella morto è vivo
viva a posto bellissimo come faccio
sbocciare io l'amore nessuno
mamma mia ci sono voluti sette anni per
ricongiungervi è bellissimo come questa
nuova trasforma un nuovo da file in un
pescatore ma certo che ci vuole
questo sogno di essere un pescatore per
prima cosa a vestire modo appropriato ok
cappello di paglia
questo serve perché non ho mai capito il
motivo però qui serve per pescare ok
come no gli ho messo il cappello di
paglia la scusa ma allora decido io cosa
devi fare
poi deve prendere nel pesce ok dagli un
oggetto che tirano su are piante ho
scritto al piontek top pesca volevi
facile la canna da pesca non l'arpione i
pesci non abboccano metti qualcosa che
gli attivi nell'acqua squalo
ecco qua no no
[Musica]
mamma mia come sei bravo la madonna
allora i cadaveri persone come ad avere
un sapore bari e catto e ho capito cosa
vuoi da me farfalla farfalla morta no mi
piace mangiare cibo colorato il
progresso cromatografico grande madonna
sanno fare qua lo prendo con la mano
monta addirittura ma spiega mito prendi
prendimi adoro mangiare cose colorate
lucente arcobaleno commestibile e magna
dell'arcobaleno commestibile bravo torta
al cioccolato va bene top magna della
magna testa torta cliccherà l'arcobaleno
non andava bene adesso sì ma scusami ma
che crede pescara balena eccolo cattura
una scuola di cioccolato tagli la cena
ok uno score giocato la cena quindi mi
immagino che sia un uomo di cioccolato
di cioccolato bagnato perfetto telo da
taglio data una scena incredibile o sei
stato veramente bravo zio sono fenomeno
ma è bellissimo
signori scribblenauts la potenza visto
gioco allucinante prove gli 6 a pescara
un uomo completa bene voglio nella mia
vita ha fatto anche di meglio comunque
56 starai sono contentissimo
questi si sono innamorati non sanno cosa
non sono proprio come intrattenersi nel
parlare questi due dunque ogni scimmia
un hobby che è un amico che abbia gusti
simili per ogni scimmia quindi devo
trovare chitarrista sto c'è la freddie
mercury di sopra volendo potevo prendere
lui troppi direi e merlino marlin marlin
garics non ti piace semplicemente mago
illusionista com l'illusionista è più
harry potter lui gag harry potter stesso
comunque poste alla messo a questa
scimmie smettere il computer piace di
videogame cry qui fa vj
bellissimo ha funzionato eh va beh siamo
entrati nel internet bellissimo come si
sa perché mi piace ai videogiochi
questa scimmia anche un cappello da
gallo che ha un amico per la scimmia da
gallo a un maxwell che sarebbe
protagonista marcello cielo questa era
l'ultima st wright prima di fini del
gioco me la ricordo dai a ogni persona
non un modo per scendere i pendii questa
l'avevo fatta questa e l'avevo fatta è
stata l'ultima cosa che ho fatto
nell'ultimo episodio me lo ricordo da lì
qualcosa della sua terra un big top
bellissimo va bene è tutto normale a
casa mia qualche le qualcosa di mistico
drago alato a tre teste sono fa
veramente a creare te a rete di drago
eccolo qua non è non ho creato niente di
quello che volevo creare ma va bene
questo è uno zombie cervello tieni
scendi con quello beh però vedo che i
cervelli comunque in qualche modo di
fanno slittare è bellissima st wright
vallate dove io l'avevo presa questa
guerra al ricordo che era l'ultima che
ho preso
nell'ultimo episodio ai non c'è mostrano
però ve l'ho fatta 58 ne mancano due è
l'esperto 60 per vedere cosa c'è in
quell'area ragazzi prove lo vediamo poi
le prossimo episodio
se volete ovviamente se non volete fa
niente però è stato bellissimo di
provare a giocare scrive ai nostri
ragazzi veramente un gioco incredibile
probabili dice 60 che cosa succede a 60
magari mi sblocca un mondo nuovo
salve finissimo signori come solito semi
semplici un documento è un mi piace
iscritti al canale fatemi sapere se
volete alle possibilità di iscrivere
fatelo capire anche dai like che mettete
a questo video e noi come sempre ci
vediamo al prossimo video ragazza
[Musica]
no